eine sekunde nach dem tod der queen da
gab es einen neuen könig einer der sich
sehr lange auf diesen job vorbereiten
konnte der neue könig heißt ging charles
lang lebe der könig
[Musik]
die queen sein schicksal sein vater
prinz philip seine qual lady diana seine
tragödie camilla die liebe seines lebens
von prinz zu könig charles
er leidet als kind sein schottisches
internat gordon ssten erlebt er als
gefängnis er wird gemobbt geschlagen er
weint als der schnee durch die immer
offenen fenster in seinen schlafsack er
schreibt briefe des leidens
als marineoffizier stößt er sich
weltweit seine sexuellen hörner ab aber
hörig wird er nur einer der robusten
lustigen und großzügigen land lady
camilla
36 jahre lang sind sie ein liebespaar
dann endlich die heirat
[Musik]
seine lebens tragödie die traumhochzeit
1981 mit traumprinzessin lady diana
spencer die welt jubelt aber in der
nacht vor der heirat schläft charles bei
seiner camilla die zynische wahrheit
charles hat da jänner nie wirklich
geliebt
vor der trauung sehen sie sich nur 12
mal
er führt sie zum altar wie zur
schlachtbank rihanna versucht sich
später sogar schwanger umzubringen als
die geschiedene da jänner am 31 august
1997 mit ihrem milliardärs geliebten
dodi al fayed in einem schwarzen
mercedes 280 es gegen den dreizehnten
pfeiler des alma tunnels in paris rast
verfolgt von paparazzi und chauffiert
von einem angetrunkenen fahrer stöhnt
ein schals vertrauter in schlosswil
morel unsere sorgen sind vorbei
camilla hat nie in ihrem leben
gearbeitet der palast verspottet sie als
faulste frau von großbritannien aber sie
ist die liebe des lebens des neuen
königs sie macht ihn glücklich
wenn könig charles der dritte gekrönt
wird wird camilla hinter ihm sitzen mit
mini krone in seide hermelin und gold
und eigenem zepter sie wird vermutlich
den titel princess consort oder queen
konzert tragen
doch wie fit ist könig charles überhaupt
noch er macht täglich früh gymnastik er
reitet wandert viel ist gesund trinkt
wenig laut camilla stehen beide noch
voll im saft über 50 jahre wartet
charles pflichtgemäß auf den tod seiner
mutter seelisch zitternd traurig hoffend
frustriert aber
schicksalsergeben er ist ein guter
mensch und er glaubt an das gute im
menschen er ist zwar der älteste prinz
der welt aber auch der coolste grünste
harmonie suchende und liebes
sehnsüchtigst er hätte mit seinen 20
millionen jahreseinkünften ein
weltweiter playboy werden können aber er
wurde der fleißigste prinz der welt
schirmherr von 500 gemeinnützigen
organisationen und den geheimdiensten er
hat bis zu 1000 termine im jahr er führt
nachts noch tagebuch er stellt seine
pflichten über seine menschlichen
wünsche
er ist die geißel seiner eigenen krone
sein wappen spruch in deutsch ich denn
jetzt
ist seine zeit gekommen
[Musik]